ثلاث سيارات من طراز كواد كوبتر انطلقت من
الداخل الايراني واستهدفت مصنعا عسكريا في
مدينه اصفحان وهي احدى اهم المدن
الايرانيه من ناحيه الصناعات العسكريه حيث
تضم منشات اهم المنشات الايرانيه النوويه
النظام الايراني اقر بالهجوم ووصفه
بالفاشل وفتح تحقيقا لمعرفه اسباب هذا
الهجوم وزار الدفاع الايرانيه اعلنت ان
الدفاع الجوي اصاب واحده من الطائرات
المسيره فيما وقعت الطائرتان الاخريان
وفشلت بس قولون امريكيون قالوا لي ووصفه
جورنا ان اسرائيل استهدفت مجمع عن دفاعيا
بايران بطائرات مسيره وهي اول عمليه
اسرائيليه في عهد نتانيا واظهرت مقاطع
فيديو لحظه الانفجار الذي بدا قويه
[موسيقى]
اليوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نقلا عن اجهزه غربيه ان الموساد قد يقف
وراء الهجوم على مخزن للمسيرات باصفهان
تصريح جاء قبل معلومات وصفيه طبعا
اوكرانيا هي الاخرى علقت على الحادثه
وربطتها بالحرب الجاريه على اراضي حيث قال
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ان استهداف مواقع
في اصفهان الايرانيه له صله مباشره بالحرب
في بلادنا وطبعا بالحرب الدائره مع روسيا
[موسيقى]